thank you
[Music]
what's going on with Tori Spelling you
guys ever think about that
I've been wondering yeah although she
hasn't done anything since 90210 a long
time because of her dad right didn't he
isn't he the creator of 90210 yeah so
for those of you guys who don't know her
father oh wow Aaron's spelling is
responsible for some of the biggest hit
TV shows in the 90s of the 2000s he
holds the record for having the most
credits as a producer and executive ah
what's been going on with Luke Perry he
passed away all right so uh Aaron's
spelling made 90210 Melrose Place
Charmed seventh heaven Charlie's Angels
Mod Squad wow all of those charms so
good yeah so good at making TV shows
yeah captured teenage girls
um he knew the [__] form yeah oh what
did what did he what did she do all
right well she didn't do anything it's
just that like uh Aaron's spelling was
nearly a billionaire and he would place
his daughter Tori Spelling in like
certain shows all right uh you just
always see her like she was in Saved by
the Bell as like screeches nerd love
interest if you remember that she was
also Donna 90210 and uh for a while when
she lived with her parents it was
um and I believe still is the largest
house in California oh wow the largest
house it had uh it was so big that Tori
says that she's never even seen every
room holy [__] imagine that she's never
even seen it and uh it has insane how do
you have such a house that you've never
seen every room it's got to be as big as
a college probably yeah it's massive and
also some some rooms were servant
quarters so she wouldn't even be going
in there you don't go where they go so
like like listen to this at a barber
shop a bar a billiard room an arcade
they had two gift wrapping rooms one was
a Christmas based one and one was like
an everyday gift wrapping room wow very
functional huh um uh yeah bowling alley
had a it was 56 000 square feet oh
and about a year ago uh it sold for 165
million wow oh they moved out they
didn't do so well in life huh no because
Aaron Spelling passed away in 2006. but
then she didn't want to keep it
it didn't go to her oh Aaron Spelling
died in 2006 and left most of his
fortune to his wife
which is not her mom
it is her mom oh okay okay what kind of
makes sense though where she can make
the calls on on it on the estate oh yeah
but they don't they don't get along so
well that's hard Gloria and the mom Tori
only got kept the Flames kindled yeah
that's already only got twenty got 800k
which you know that's very little in
comparison to the rest of it but like
for a lifestyle that she was used to
yeah
um she had massive money problems she
couldn't manage it and she even admits
like look oh look at my life of course I
had money problems I don't know how to
manage money I was born into this yeah I
got rooms I've never even seen before
yeah but she also made a lot of her own
right like being in shows and all that
so it was because her dad placed her on
all these things that she never actually
broke out and did her own things you
could kind of it it's to be assumed that
that's why she got the rule she got yeah
and I think if that even happens to you
and let's say you do have the talent
other people might have an animosity and
not want to hire you um so what happened
she did these shows didn't she get paid
so she just never put the money away
correctly and she spent it but it's not
enough yeah she probably doesn't know
how to manage the money that's coming in
easy come easy go huh because the
lifestyle that she's used to would never
in a million years match what she makes
on her own oh true oh that's true
because if you got like a whole house
with just the Arctic experience like
just Penguins just chilling one day and
like yeah you can't recreate that plus
uh unless your brain goes sometimes she
got into tax debt oh [__] and she had a
really really messy divorce oh no and uh
because of this where her mom is like
you know they're kind of strange she's
on her own she had she ended up with
five kids she had custody of them all I
guess and recently has been seen staying
at an LA motel with all five kids no
damn while her 77 year old mom is off
being kind of like a sugar mama to this
37 year old dude Josh Flagg from Million
Dollar Listing hey but he's [__]
making her come all the time so
so she's probably like I like where your
mind goes sometimes
she's probably like he does more for me
than you ever have Tori yeah yeah it
makes me feel alive and young again yeah
it's pretty crazy because like you know
she's uh the mom ended up with like
majority of that money and now like
she's you know kind of showering this
young fellow but but we see it as oh
poor girl right but what if her mom's
like don't worry you've always been a
spoiled brat you can't get any of this
money until you learn responsibility
it's the parents I try to tell you but
you were just a daddy's girl could be
yeah it could be that I mean this is her
uh with the with the kids like they
coming out of that Motel this Motel is
like a it's like a Travel Lodge type
deal so it's like oh poor girl you gotta
travel like the rest of us now
I love Travel Lodge dude it's just
racist
Travelodge it's like one of the best
motels out there oh oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's nothing
wrong with the motel travel launch it
just looks like hey the difference
between a motel and a hotel is the doors
face out because it's a motor hotel and
you can park your [__] car and your
RV and all that stuff and then the doors
are facing out for easy access that's
the only difference it's not cheaper
yeah
because the amenities are way less but
that's what that's where she was like
staying whoa I think I know what I said
in Hollywood it's really crazy she was
living in the
State's largest house that's crazy crazy
you could like be on top of the world
literally and then [__] like in a
decade or two yeah God damn what's that
that's what happened to America's
richest family do you know about the
Vanderbilts they were like The Waltons
but times a hundred who are The Waltons
like the Walmart family uh yeah so right
they're like ball and ass Americans
right and it only took them like three
generations to squander it all yeah
three generations so like it was Grandpa
[__] made it and then the sun like
tried to keep it going and then the
grandson destroyed it and that's how it
happens historically it's hard to keep
money after three generations second
generation tries to sustain and then
third one is by the third one it's all
gone that's Mom that's her mom candy and
then the dude Josh oh for sure it's like
a white Vietnamese lady
wow yo he's eating that [__] up though
he's putting in work hey good for him
he's earning his if if you have to
[__] eat Grandma [__] every day [__]
dude what made this stick out to me is
like I was wondering about this because
when I saw that like why is Tori
Spelling in like recent news and I was I
was always curious about like back when
I was hosting this thing for complex the
the people were like okay it's down like
before I got the job they were like it's
down to you and Tori Spelling I was like
Tori Spelling wants this job why oh what
a girl yeah it's I guess it's hard for
her to get and you still ousted her well
I mean also she's way older I guess it's
kind of like a so do you feel guilty you
took away from no because in her
family's table no because that job
didn't pay [__] anyway but she needed
that money more than you she dodged a
bullet that he took it for but yeah it's
um it's an interesting thing that like
what happens in this situation does do
you think the mom should give her a
little bit of help I don't know I feel
bad because like it's so funny to make
fun of rich people and people who grew
up rich but like they were born into it
like they don't know what the anything
to anybody yeah I've never like done
anything bad
she is 50. but don't you've been like
out of the super a-listers of the 90s
like she's one of the most drama-free
ones you don't hear much yeah she
doesn't hurt anybody she's just like it
she's like a victim of like a lavish
lifestyle that she no longer has access
to I want to hear her mom as to what
like why because it's just unusual like
why would you cut her off completely
what is the falling out you guys had
yeah plus you could also like have a
Fallout with the daughter but then still
like have empathy towards your
grandchildren you're not right and still
set up some sort of fun yeah but that's
why that that that feels weird to me
like a tough love thing why is it so bad
yeah the five grandchildren though you
know what I mean
dude yeah it is interesting too to be
like a sugar mama to another dude that's
also kind of well off yeah isn't he like
balling isn't he like a ball in real
estate dude but then apparently she
takes him on these trips and pays for
all his [__] for him well maybe because
the level of Sugar Mama that he could do
he can't afford yeah it's like yeah he
could buy first class tickets but she's
like I'll take you on my personal yacht
yeah and he goes oh I don't have a yacht
yeah what they probably spend in a week
together we'll probably feed like Tori
Spelling's family for like a month have
you guys ever been in any sugar
situations I wish never never
I'll tell you who this is after we cut
cameras but like there's a friend of
mine who he's like A-list now but there
was a point where he had a sugar daddy
and he's not gay the sugar daddies get
it yeah but so he's not gay but he would
suck dick well he doesn't admit it but
basically he ended up meeting this like
benefactor dude like Rich foreign guy
and this is what at his brokest
he this dude came around and uh I guess
this guy owned like a farm
so he would send like shipments of uh
[__] meat and steaks and uh Farmer
John filet mignons and stuff that's
pretty cool and he gave him like a a one
of one like Mercedes that like was made
for him to like drive around wow can we
give him like stipends and stuff
everything and then we were like just
tell us the truth are you [__] this
guy
this he just like
that you see his penis once you know
it's funny because we were all broke we
would get these shipments of filet
mignon and we would be cooking it at a
George Foreman grill
blasphemy yeah that's a good setup but
now this dude is like a this guy's like
a huge star now and he's like I don't
gotta suck dick no more
I'm sure he did yeah he was like
maintaining that that the dude wasn't
trying to uh do that with him but
there's no but the comp what what like
what would the arrangement be like I'll
come over and you'll spend time with me
and we'll have long conversations he
would be with him like three days out of
the week and we would just not see him
because we lived in the same building so
we were just not seeing damn do you
tricks yeah I thought it would be hot
because of the British accent
but yeah it's it's funny when you get
into these like sugar situations and
like I wonder how many of those have
happened throughout life for like
different people and then they just have
to like put it behind them because
they're like no yeah that's cool hey
sometimes they climb up you know it gets
a little bit rough but as long as you
get up to that next level you're taking
the climb right you know what I mean I
ain't mad at it I might just suck a dick
once
laughs